(tranquil music)
- [Narrator] Located in Sicily, Italy,
is an ancient cemetery.
But to see it, don't look to the ground;
look up into the valley walls.
(tranquil music)
Necropolis di Pantalica is
made up of around 5,000 tombs
that are carved into
a limestone rock face,
some of which are
believed to have been made
more than 3,000 years ago.
(tranquil music)
The tombs are built like artificial caves,
small in size and are either square,
rectangular, or elliptical in shape.
(tranquil music)
The surrounding area is lush
with native flora and wildlife
and is completely unspoiled
by infrastructure.
(tranquil music)
It was listed as a UNESCO
World Heritage Site in 2005.
Currently, the site is
accessible by foot only.
However, a walk through this valley
is a reflective trip back in time.
(tranquil music)